all right what's going on guys this is
rob and we are back with the banner of
war yeah there we go i was getting ready
to say like the banner of hulk
uh so this is part two the next part the
next issue comes out in a week i believe
uh may 25th so it looks like it is a
weekly series which is pretty awesome
what we end up doing here is picking up
with really not just the avengers kind
of everybody right the avengers and the
fantastic four because the incredible
hulk sort of going off the radar not
even off the radar like going off the
rails and just doing his own thing is
always a pause for concern and in
general everybody really wants to know
what's going on with him especially
because it's basically banner
controlling the incredible hulk now of
course they end up locating his location
or end up finding his location and the
way in which they do it's one of the
weirdest things because what ends up
happening is iron man basically tells
reed richards because he essentially
reveals that the place in which they're
in is essentially an arena right where
thor and hulk are basically fighting and
that it's basically just the black hand
of a celestial that was quite literally
retrofitted into a gladiatorial arena
itself and where reed's kind of like i
mean that's you know and and it really
tries to finish a statement the response
of iron man is that's awesome
now of course reed asked the question
how in the world did you do this now
here's a cool thing is that iron man
says that he has a network of deep space
satellites slave to his internal
mainframe they constantly sweep for
activity in places explored or not and
that yesterday he picked up a sound
which from reed's perspective shouldn't
be possible and so in response like the
you know iron man basically says yeah
like a sound right in space something so
loud this vibrational frequency
completely fried one of iron man's space
satellites and he says from there he
triangulated the source of the sonic
disturbance and then isolated it and he
says you know what it was it was a voice
it was basically a voice so loud that it
blew a satellite out of the sky from 2
000 miles away and it said hulk smash
and so reed is kind of flabbergasted
here right because this is not something
that iron man normally does one thing to
know and i love the way that donnie
cates does this one thing to know when
it comes to intelligence levels reed
richards is smarter than tony stark
that's not really a debatable thing
right it's not one of those things where
it's like i mean they change positions
no like reed's at the very top and
that's literally what he says he's like
well that's that's impressive tony right
i had you know no no no disrespect
intended here but i had no idea that
those kinds of resources or at least
that you had those kinds of resources or
quite frankly the scientific know-how to
sweep the depths of unknown space like
that and then the response of iron man
is no i'm messing around reid i don't
have the ability to do that right like i
have no idea how to do any of that stuff
thor's ravens told me where where hulk
was
literally
thor's ravens were just hanging out with
spider-man and he's like what's up
so i absolutely love that i love that
whole it's one of the reasons why i love
donnie kate's writing so much now here's
the thing about this while tony stark
doesn't really have the ability or the
intelligence level to create satellites
that orbit earth and essentially sweep
deep space he does have the intelligence
to build satellites and put them in
different parts of space and in fact his
his intelligence in relation to
space-faring escapades that was really
put on full on full display when he
joined the guardians of the galaxy that
was really really cool but in response
of course you know captain america kind
of steps up and says look if thor's
already engaged with banner then we
basically just have to stay here until
we have more intel at the very least one
they're fighting in a gladiatorial ring
which captain america again really is
able to pick up on the situation and
just be like they're literally in the
best place to fight right like a place
designed for fighting we're not really
gonna have to worry about innocence and
if we do well i mean they're hanging out
in a gladiatorial arena right you pay
your money and take your chances and
sometimes when you're in the audience of
a gladiatorial fight you might lose your
life just kind of goes with the
territory you know it's that kind of a
thing right now the funny thing about
this is that the response of iron man is
no i'm gonna go find him
no there's a reason why tony stark does
this there's a reason why of course iron
man's response is like no like i'm
you're not going of course it's kind of
a bickering back and forth between the
two is like no i'm absolutely doing that
and of course he starts firing up his
thrusters but what tony stark says is
he's like when when banner initially
broke through the defenses that i had
and he went through that portal i looked
into his eyes man and that's a guy that
tried to kill me right like legitimately
tried to kill me now one part of this is
tony stark just pissed off that the
incredible hulk tried to kill him but
another part is a straight-up
recognition of the situation and just
being like this is the incredible hulk
at his most dangerous not his strongest
but at his most dangerous this guy had a
desire to take me out and there's a as
far as i could tell looking in that
dude's eyes he has no reservation about
killing the rest of us so i'm gonna go
deal with this guy now of course as he's
talking captain america is like are you
even here and the response of iron man's
like i'm never at these meetings captain
like i've got places to be he's
literally piloting the thing remote and
then just takes off in this giant suit
of armor which we'll talk about here in
a second but at that point you switch
back over to the fight between thor and
and hulk and if you guys recall from the
last video that we had we had an instant
where essentially thor had thrown the
hammer mjolnir which is essentially
inhabited by the spirit of odin directly
at the hulk and when the two made
contact it allowed odin's spirit to jump
from the hammer into banner's mind and
so now you have basically the spirit of
odin facing off against the mind of
banner now the cool thing about this is
on the surface you might look at that
and just be like odin versus banner
right like obviously odin would win here
but there's this amazing moment where
odin is just like look man like i'm way
beyond you bruce spanner you have no
chance of defeating me here so stand
down and the responsive banner is no
you're not a man odin like you're a
ghost you're not real and you're in my
head and in my head i am god here and of
course immediately ensnares odin and
then as soon as that happens of course
he basically initiates automatic
defenses which essentially allows the
incredible hulk body to just fight on
its own while the incredible hulk serves
as again kind of the engine for all the
strength and everything and banner's
mine just kind of controls everything
right so it quite literally is the
incredible hulk body operating on
autopilot now the thing about this is
that of course as you have banner and
you have uh odin you know confronting
one another that thor finally has enough
and then just headbutts the hell out of
the incredible hulk and when that
happens it basically shakes and jogs or
at least jars the mind of banner and
sends them back to el paso right
recalling that memory of course where
odin's basically there and he's a
bartender just kind of watching
everything unfold now here's the kicker
to this we never found out what happened
in el paso all we knew is that some of
them
transpired in el paso texas and banner
basically
restructured or redesigned the
incredible hulk in such a way to where
the incredible persona would just fight
an endless onslaught of enemies in the
form of a simulation and wouldn't really
know it was a simulation per se and then
in turn banner would just control the
mind of the incredible hulk and the
incredible hulk body would stay the
incredible hulk body and then they would
just leave and go do their thing right
presumably go into wherever or confront
whatever whatever the case happened to
be but we didn't know exactly how we got
to that point all we knew is that
something happened where things popped
off and so what ended up going on here
is that in the aftermath of al ewing's
immortal hulk run quite literally when
bruce banner and the incredible hulk or
really immortal hulk had defeated the
one below all essentially the answer to
the question what happens when the one
above all hulks out this led to them
just kind of going forward and doing
their thing and they were by all
standards of measurement effectively a
team right like they were just kind of
working in unison it was as close as you
get to a happy ending for banner and the
incredible hulk and what ended up
happening is that there came a point
when they arrived in el paso and that
there was a kind of not really a
skirmish of sorts but just one where uh
banner had just kind of knocked over or
i'm sorry a guy had knocked over
banner's drink and the guy was like
apologetic said hey look man then banner
just you know almost flew off the handle
and started to freak out but of course
things seem to calm down relatively fast
what ended up happening here is while
banner's not entirely sure how it took
place in effect the incredible hulk's
rage if you can call it that almost
became this kind of viral thing and
literally spread to everybody in this
bar in el paso right 17 people and they
all just started going nuts right just
becoming like these extreme hulk
personas and just referring to banner is
like puny banner so almost as though the
incredible hulk itself spread out as a
contagion uh and then in turn everything
started going sideways right the
incredible hulk's coronavirus so the
thing about this is that in that moment
when things began to go nuts that what
happened is suddenly banner was yanked
out of control that in effect his
personality was shunted off to the
background and another personality took
hold that in effect all banner could see
is blackness he had no idea what was
going on and whatever this personality
was that seeds control killed everybody
in el paso like literally destroyed them
all i mean ripping arms off right just
just just abs an absolute bloodbath
right an absolute massacre now given
what we've seen so far we can largely
assume this personality is the mental
manifestation of the titan hulk whereas
we did see the physical manifestation uh
in the last story arc that we did right
so in the the smash not story so that's
most likely what's going on here again
we don't necessarily have a definitive
answer but what ended up going on is
that banner came to this realization
that if the incredible hulk by whatever
manner and whatever means whether it's a
result of coming into contact with the
one below all or something that he
doesn't fully understand yet that if the
incredible hulk if his rage is so
extreme that it can actually spread out
to the people around him then why simply
just not use it right it was an idea
that it occurred to him based on all
their experiences together that over the
course of banner's life it was one of
these things where he had always tried
to work with the incredible hulk you
know that he had tried to to utilize his
capabilities or even the two of them
would like merge personalities with a
great hulk and become like professor
hulk you know different things along
those lines but there's always been this
thing where like banner's kind of been
trying to work with the hulk his mind
suddenly shifted and said why not just
use the hulk why not just use his rage
right if really like situations like
this in el paso are essentially a result
of what happens when the incredible hulk
has all this rage but can't do anything
with it assuming that's actually what's
going on then why not put it to good use
and effectively just become a kind of
savior of sorts and so that's basically
what he did that's why he engineered the
hulk the way that he did which was a
genius idea the problem is there really
isn't a whole lot of time to go on here
that initially thor was just going to
kind of continue on and let them do
their thing but what thor ends up doing
is basically summoning the hammer back
which of course brings the uh brings the
odin persona back with it or the odin
spirit back with it and yanks it out of
the mind of banner and where odin gets
pissed off and is like why did you pull
me out like we were so close i had the
ability to talk this guy down the
response of thor is because we've got
bigger problems right like we do not
have any more time and when the question
is like why like what why have we ran
out of time here he's just like uh
here's the thing there's a huge threat
that arrived now the other part of this
and this is a really cool concept the
other part of this is that the
incredible hulk persona is now the
dominant persona controlling its own
body the problem here is the incredible
hulk persona does not know this is not a
simulation the incredible hulk thinks
this is a simulation that's one of the
things to know because the way those
simulations work that allow the
incredible hulk to just fight an endless
wave of enemies which basically allow
banner to amp up the incredible hulk's
strength or bring the incredible hook
strength down really takes place in a
variety of circumstances and the
environment changes all the time and so
if your environment shifted from one
moment to the next everything from just
extreme situations to basically docile
or more toned down situations and then
suddenly you were thrust into the real
world you wouldn't be able to
differentiate between the two you
wouldn't know what's real and what's not
real and so that's exactly where the
incredible hulk is he doesn't know that
it's not a simulation and so it's kind
of a crazy thing because in that moment
it basically highlights this idea the
incredible hulk could go on a tear
believing all of it's not real that
there's no real concern here or anything
like that now of course the major threat
that they're contending with which is
pretty awesome is basically iron man
celestial hulk buster armor and this
thing is enormous i mean it's absolutely
huge although if you're gonna have a
suit of armor that's designed to
basically destroy what could potentially
be a celestially powered hulk uh
especially when you're talking about
titan hulk you're probably gonna need
something this huge what it can do
though we don't know we'll have to find
out for uh the video for next week with
that being said guys
we're gonna bring this to an end thank
you all for watching and i will catch
you all later
peace